yeah I'm just gonna make some copies in
here perfect cover
nailed it so apparently the new captain
survived and his heart attack not the
craziest thing that happened at the
precinct today we kissed three hours ago
yes we did kiss each other for reals
reals reals listen I know you said you
don't want to take ops but I really like
you I like you too good but why don't we
start dating and it makes things weird
at work so let's just keep it light and
breezy see where it goes totally yeah so
how do we keep it light and breezy
I know a comprehensive set of rules how
am i attracted to you doesn't matter I
am go roll one let's not tell anyone so
we can figure out what this is first
smart rule number two let's not put
labels on it we're not boyfriend and
girlfriend we're just firms II Ben
jingle bin great rule number three
let's not have sex right away cool
Ames you're two minutes late I called
all the emergency rooms I know I went
home from your place to shower and I'm
so tired that I fell asleep while
shaving my legs well we went to bed so
early property brothers was over at
10:00 I mean sex we do it she's tired
from all the doing it there you are
thank God
hey did you bring me January 14 2014
detectives Peralta and Santiago
conducted surveillance from a rooftop at
397 Barton Street this is where we came
the night I won our bet and you fell in
love with me Jake the night that you
flirted with me for 20 seconds and I
became obsessed with you forever
ready
I'm sorry I freaked out and ran away
it's okay
just because you messed up the practice
test doesn't mean you're gonna fail the
real I didn't mess it up
I got a hunnert and 2% I found a
spelling error in one question I gave
myself extra credit then why'd you leave
because that was the first time it
really hit me when I passed the exam
I'll actually be a sergeant what if
everything changes between us that's why
you came here these are so good right
now I don't want to screw that up by
getting transferred or becoming your
boss names I've always known you were
gonna be my boss this is your dream from
before we were dating and yeah things
might change a little but for the better
right you can finally get premium cable
check out all those shows on epics look
you can't be afraid to be successful
you're too good for that
I love you love you too wait the test we
gotta get you out of here great I'm
gonna be surgeon have you sergeant you
don't have a key for this random roof
door do you
it's called taxi because it's yellow and
it takes you where you need to be drug
dealers have gotten so creative it used
to just be crack and then they'd be like
hey we got a new one what are we gonna
call this and they go I don't know crank
this is certainly worth following up on
Santiago take Boyle in work the case
oh but Jake I mean detective Peralta
brought in the perp so the point
Peralta Boyle can work the case actually
sir I think we were kind of hoping we
could work the case together
oh are you two no longer smooshing
booties yes that's exactly I was gonna
finish my sentence figured we are still
dating it's all aboveboard HR gets daily
updates and our bcc'd on all our emails
to each other
that's why HR Jim keeps high-fiving me
we begin we're all great stories begin
in the quaint little town a french fry
village after that we're gonna move our
adventure over to cheeseburger Mountain
which consists do you guessed it up
turkey burgers I'm kidding it's
cheeseburgers
this is kind of just stuffing you can
avoid that but it's attached to the
Thanksgiving turkey theme because I was
thinking about that a lot up in the jail
and finally we have a big old Passover
brisket cuz you know I love my mom if
you would all take a seat while I make a
toast kindly raise your two liters to
freedom to you and most importantly to
orange drink and sex with Amy sorry
should have said that last part hey
honey
thanks for bringing Roger back you're
very welcome
hey by the way amy was really nervous to
meet you so don't judge her too harshly
for all the weird singing oh no I'm
dating my son of a [ __ ] ex-husband Who
am I the judge I think she's really
great
I think you're really great too she's
very good at lip-reading
I wouldn't say I'm very good I mean deaf
people they're the real talents
I just can't stop I'll let you guys talk
I'll just close my eyes he's leaving our
plan worked we saved our own honeymoon
and fun bonus we cheered up holt okay
it's time to celebrate you know what
that means this bee needs a see in her a
oh my god this baby needs a coconut
nerds oh I thought you were saying this
music oh my god
that was my reaction all right I'll go
get us a couple of coconuts I kept
thinking how did anyone swap my key and
then it hit me they didn't they swap the
safe one of the hand mades I'm assuming
fake Charles took my safe and then of
Amy deposited a look-alike where did you
get fake Charles so he'd help you
nothing in fact he gave me something the
power of financial freedom I invested in
a pyramid scheme it's no time to go into
it right now okay so while we all tried
to figure out who had the real key fake
Charles broke into the safe remove the
tracker and led Terry in the whole squad
on a wild goose chase my only question
is which box is the belt in well good
luck figuring it out because the clock
is ticking talking it's that one no the
dust pattern on top doesn't match its
neighbors you see Jake I'm always gonna
be one step ahead of you you've lost the
ability to surprise me you're just plain
boring again we are take on our very
loving relationship and it's midnight so
I guess I'm an amazing human slash
genius yeah although you might want to
read the inscription on that there bill
why oh no what does it say Amy Santiago
will you marry me
surprise I'm sorry infused I don't know
what's happening right now
I'm so confused I don't know what's
happening right now title your sex tape
oh my god I'm shaking I'm definitely
gonna cry title your sex tape wait is
this really happening is this part of
the heist and this is part of the heist
I will dump you so hard no please names
like it's really happening okay it's not
part of the heist I promise this is you
are I love how beautiful you are
I love your face and I love your but I
should've written this down first no no
it's okay go on
I love how much you pretend to like die
hard I like the second one you don't
have to okay yeah you're kind and you're
funny and you're the best person I know
and
the best detective also for reals I love
your butt I love yours too gross Amy
Santiago will you marry me
Jake Peralta I will marry you
thank you so much hey shirt goes this
little [ __ ] escape so that on it teach
did you just mmm-hmm did you say mmm-hmm
hey Gina just texted me she said weird I
didn't even realize they were dating
JK's so happy for you [ __ ] so Jake
tell us everything
did you call any stat first I actually
did mr. Santiago I'm calling to inform
you that I plan to ask your daughter to
marry me but since it's 2017 I am NOT
asking for your permission as she is not
your property nor would she be mine if
she chooses to say yes she's a strong
independent woman and she don't need no
man that being said I truly hope she
says yes but it's her decision so just
back off oh that was perfect
What did he say I have no idea I left a
voicemail I'm terrified of him
not to talk out of turn but I think I
get credit for giving Jake the idea to
propose a day in a kitchen so what I'm
saying is vanilla yogurt is good but
pair it with a blueberry yogurt and both
of them taste even better did it yes I
did not get it
but speaking of yogurt you've eaten six
GPS devices this week you should
definitely see a doctor what mmm look
Sarge I think everyone knows that I
planted the idea in Jake's head eight
years ago oh hi I'm starting today
detective Santiago Oh detective Peralta
welcome aboard
I'm hearing wedding bells hi detective
Boyle I actually really slowed things
down it took like four years for me to
forget that memory yeah my own worst
enemy look no one gave me the idea I
decided to ask Amy to marry me all on my
own on April 28th there's a typo in this
crossword puzzle
I don't get it seems pretty normal I
don't know what to tell you
that's just when I knew romantic
epiphanies you're dope Thank You Rosa
please be seated friends colleagues
gawking New Yorkers we are here today to
celebrate the marriage of Jake Peralta
and Amy Santiago I've known you both for
the last five years and it has been a
true pleasure to watch your distracting
childish rivalry evolved into a
distracting childish courtship and now
into what I'm sure will be a distracting
childish marriage I'm proud of you and I
love you both permission to say it back
permission granted
you